sophomore year will father gourmet Club
and mr. right like a chef's club listen
to this listen to this
that's not regular high school had a
thing called the gourmet Club and one
Sunday every month you got together you
rented a bus you paid dues you had to be
a julienne above a senior yeah I do it
mr. Graff and three other teachers [ __ ]
would take you into the some famous
restaurant and then you eat the food and
go back to one of the teachers house he
doesn't anymore so you just take you
Undine listen to me right you in the car
your parents know if the restaurant a
bus a bus and you had to pay to be part
of the gourmet Club right like every
school has [ __ ] [ __ ] organization
biography Club go make club the first
plumbers club every high school
everybody in this room was part of some
[ __ ] [ __ ] organization in [ __ ]
high school okay in my high school they
had like the dudes who built the sets
and all that stupidity but they also had
but they also had the gourmet Club and
you would meet once a month in a high
school so just imagine that on a
sweatshirt that you need to vote is dead
oh my god and all that dependent oh yeah
all that [ __ ] that guy's name was Bob
Bowman look at the Box Bob Bowman you
see that we'd said when we were in high
school from Hawaii on sticks a little
rapper
vacuum-seal the 1970s they're ahead of
the game man 35 hours for [ __ ] three
joints we thought we were getting robbed
that we would oh my gosh [ __ ] from the
wire right this is our crazy one you
guys are smoking hibiscus so we go to
[ __ ] we go to [ __ ] we go to
Chinatown I take the lead China Chinese
food and then you go back to somebody's
house so it got so pathetic it means the
the gourmet Club that that one year let
the south was it and I was a sophomore
and we all gotten a bus and went with
some [ __ ] restaurant on the way back
went to pollute ops
went to pollute the pollute oh she had a
beautiful house boundaries being crossed
the school
no no there'd be a bunch of teachers
there yeah the question is getting worse
so there'd be a bunch of peaches and ask
you stupid questions about the
restaurant and you had to make believe
like it hope the egg rolls were great
you know I've been to a few places and
sometimes the egg rolls are salty
so listen good you're a part of the
front of Yale is my requirement for an
eggroll is salty nation to me done so
we're there maybe huh
where there may be 20 minutes we take
all these [ __ ] students and really on
the up and up they're talking about the
oreganata and the clam convention of the
Klan I mean my goombazz look at each
other will like listen pass the hat
around lambs oreganata you can even have
clams oreganata will clams Casino
oh [ __ ] are you is oregano oregano like
adding a spice is clams oreganata okay
which is like there's big clam that's
what [ __ ] Gentiles eat that makes me
grab my pen I would love to either bake
our 20 had to copper kettle
what's that restaurant where people they
give you a chocolate [ __ ] fountain
that sounds good I want to put my finger
in this one I'm gonna [ __ ] chocolate
ah ah Golden Corral and Corral like crap
Golden Corral once a month we'll have
baked clams you go in there you end up
[ __ ] dead you understand me don't
even go hang out of your ass oh my god
it's a [ __ ] Horror Show so don't go
too baked around get baked clams that's
what be before people like in [ __ ]
Montana go to like what's that
restaurant
what's the Italian place where people go
Carabas though Olive Garden all of God
the Italian place Olive Garden they got
olive limit red flag you know that when
you go to Utah we're going to Salt Lake
City one yeah that's the best that's the
biggest pile of God in the country for
real food I miss out where that's where
the most action in the country is that's
where the most at that Olive Garden our
way what are people doing just finger in
each other your line [ __ ] breadsticks
fishing another four lines of salad I
like the endless salad it's the food
that [ __ ] your jaw julep attendants
oh no no no you guys yeah you're done
eggplant parm I hear buy some the pasta
fazool when I was in Pittsburgh that's
what will keep me together for three
days Pittsburgh scooters that works we
find a lot the Pittsburgh Jack you've
got the whole south I got the Menuhin
the gyros were delicious the pork fried
rice they don't [ __ ] around and up the
corner was man of God and I had it every
day for lunch like a savage Olive Garden
for lunch possible so
and the egg salad has been able to go to
the [ __ ] get the egg roll with the
pork fried rice for dinner
can you always say pasta fazool the way
you say pasta fazool it makes me pee a
little
what [ __ ] could be laughter puzzle
your possible and just made I don't know
if you know this he said I'll show you
the pictures from change regulator
it's not like it's not like his friend
like oh we took a group picture I know
he has pictures of his food I don't want
to take pictures of people you take
pictures of your food when I go to bed
you pay but do you like you put filters
in it you take pride in the photo no one
remember like [ __ ] Felix Unger what
do you do jerk oscillator no he just
cried in a show features everybody want
to show these [ __ ] magazine what the
[ __ ] you know what the [ __ ] I can show
him you'll send me a photo what I should
eat and I'll show him how being going it
and winter this place in Santa Monica
but a beach I go Rudy's
spicy mom yeah yeah galimov since I was
16 I've been going there well I had
again on tap sounds like imma get on top
you understand it's like a bowl EJ's
Yankee pot roast for the chorizo in the
middle are you [ __ ] kidding my life
no-parole the [ __ ] you make a roux
look look at the Jew bakery a [ __ ] a
[ __ ] strawberry shortcake
who takes a pen I didn't eat it I just
take a picture to Shelley's I don't know
look at this look at the Chinese food
this is gonna be a down the corner from
where you got bananas bro you see this
is the metal not only metal showing this
country no more these fools don't know
nothing about metal look at those [ __ ]
egg rolls you're gonna come to me I used
to weigh four hundred eighteen pounds
and it was solid muscle
why because I ain't the best I did [ __ ]
around look at it with his own spare
ribs